des poubelles incendies des débris aussi
après une troisième soirée de violentes
manifestation contre le passage de force
de la réforme des retraites plus de 120
personnes ont été arrêtées
il faut que ce soit un petit peu un
petit peu plus cru au niveau des maifs
parce qu'il y a que ça pour faire
entendre Macron parce que Macron ne le
voit pas
et tous ces déchets incendiées
s'ajoutent aux poubelles qui jonchent
les rues de Paris les éboueurs entamment
bientôt leur troisième semaine de grève
pour protester contre cette réforme des
retraites des rats en journée des
poubelles à n'en plus finir
ville salle très très sale
un timide ramassage des ordures c'est
toutefois amorcé dimanche après une
réquisition de la police mais au-delà
des rassemblements massifs des bureaux
de députés ont aussi été vandalisés
samedi comme celui-ci à Nice surtout
l'illuvisé le président des républicains
affirme qu'on veut faire pression sur
son vote puisqu'à l'Assemblée nationale
leur dit il y aura deux votes
susceptibles de faire tomber le
gouvernement borne qui a eu recours à un
article de la Constitution pour faire
passer sans vote la réforme des
retraites la première motion de censure
celle du rassemblement national
d'extrême droite à peu de chances
d'aboutir la deuxième présentée par un
groupe parlementaire indépendance
centriste à laquelle pourrait se rallier
des membres du parti les républicains
mais qui est elle aussi loin d'une issue
favorable d'autres pays en Europe ont
pourtant réussi à dépolitiser ce débat
au Danemark l'âge de la retraite est
indexée à l'ESP érance de vie il
pourrait passer à 70 ans en 2040 ici
aimait le mieux Radio-Canada Montréal